[Musique]
bush est là mais bon jour il ya de la
lumière chez vous et moi la lumière est
un petit peu de chaleur une douce
chaleur j'espère que vous allez
apprécier bienvenue chez la merci d'une
en aparté ravis de vous accueillir
s'ébauche avoue oui j'adore attends je
vais descendre avait commencé par le bas
lorsque tu déjà je m'affole alors ce qui
me fait plaisir c'est que j'avais ça
chez moi à feucherolles ya juste
quelques années
et je trouve que c'est vachement bien
quoi alors c'est pas mal ça nous fait
déjà un bon point alors non le bon c'est
comme ça le bon point c'est à dire que
là alors chez vous la faire courte
c'est à dire que c'est ma deuxième
maison au bord du sable avec de très
très belles chaises longues avec une
mère à tomber par terre et ça c'est mon
paradis caché c'est l'île maurice et
voilà avec avec un vrai talent vous
plongez beaucoup je crois alors plonge
oui je plonge il d'ailleurs moi j'y vais
depuis 35 ans donc j'ai pu découvrir
malheureusement que voilà la mère a
beaucoup changé là bas mais mais ce que
je fais c'est que j'ai tendance tous les
jours à traverser la baie à la nage
parce que j'adore nager et que ça
entretient que et que voilà on est bien
quand on est là bas alors c'est quoi ça
c'est quoi ça bas à fournès vous faire
plaisir un gâteau alors on s'est dit que
la tarte au citron normalement ça
devrait vous séduire ce pas mal c'est
pas mal j'ai dix ans près du fromage
j'aurais pu aussi oui non c'est bien à
tarte au citron c'est bien c'est bien là
il vient et bonbons au passage je crois
que vous avez toujours non vous en piqué
de temps en temps mais c'est surtout
pour vous rappeler votre enfant ça c'est
pour les bons souvenirs j'en ai vendu
des kilos je pouvais avec une dextérité
pour faire les sachets pendant que les
chéquiers faisait autre chose ouais
c'est ça moi quand j'étais enfant alors
c'était pas vraiment les bonbons c'était
à l'époque de pâques à l'époque de
paquets à l'époque de noël c'est les
petits sachets avec le petit noeud est
tout d'un cheveu à chez ma grand mère il
y avait une pièce où il y avait une
grande balance que j'ai chez moi
d'ailleurs garder ou ont pesé les petits
sachets et on faisait les oeufs de
pâques et tout ce à quoi bon et si vous
voulez revenir tout à l'heure vous faire
un thé ça je crois que le thé d'ailleurs
vous n'avez pas fait quand boire vous en
métier sur les jambes avec il ya une
époque
alors racontez nous raconte quand même
la blague ça c'est la blague c'est la
blague mais jugé patrick o'hare quand
j'étais très jeune drucker isère
j'avais ma meilleure amie qui s'appelait
lydia qui et voilà on était comme des
jumelles tout le temps habillés pareil
tout le temps on sait et on a bien sûr
on habite à côté comme la ville et on
allait faire du vélo et on a eu nos
premiers émois on va dire le premier
garçon qu'on a trouvé très beau et alors
on était en bicyclette toutes les deux
avec on avait une tenue très
particulière jupe de rythmiques blanche
petit polo blanc évident sur l'épaule on
jouait pas mais c'est pas grave ça
faisait bien guitare sur l'épaule et
toujours petits couteaux attachés c'est
très très moderne petits couteaux
attachés au mollet encore ne sait jamais
et donc on les avait les cuisses blanche
vous prenez bien pour aller draguer gaby
ça me fera donc évidemment n'avait
trouvé un truc qui était formidable
c'est le thé ont fait tremper le t on ce
32 dents et ça c'est une couleur
magnifique qu'on était là heureuse comme
tout avec nos cuisses à l'air est
vraiment les jambes ne le galbe de la
jambe bien bronzé en feu tout on se
retrouve à la petite rivière au fond
donc évidemment on va la petite très
bien au fond bêta ce que nous sommes et
on se dira c'est sympa il fait chaud
c'est l'été hop on va dans l'eau et la
catastrophe parce qu'évidemment on
s'éclabousse on rigole on s'amuse et là
le thé comment ça dégouline et je peux
vous dire que ce jour là je crois que
j'ai une de plus grande honte de ma vie
quelle aventure effectivement avec lui y
en aura d'autres on racontera quelques
anecdotes encore chela